des enfants
[Musique]
le temps
pour présenter ton album tu as dit sur
mes choix entre acheter une maison en
campagne ou investir beaucoup d'argent
sur ton nouvel album modifications ben
oui par année et on espère que ça me
donne une chance pour brown et décision
il ya le rêve d'avoir d'avoir à quelque
part un peu la presse
je suis un peu narcissique mais un peu
égoïste mais je pense que j'aurais peut
être prêt pour mettre un short et un
certain cage dame nature qui fera qu'à
moi qui est cool je vais acheter ma paie
au fur et à mesure que les années ont
passé et là est venue des idées plus
grandiose d'envergure mon petit côté
mégalo est sorti de manière inattendue
ce qui a fait que ben il la maison a
pris le bord finalement pu le faire et
je fasse la paix avec le fait
d'accompagner sur l'île de montréal plus
longtemps que je pense finalement mais
ses propos aurier est sorti de tout ce
cet album je suis quand même très fier
de kystes un kyste 1
pour bosser c'est un grand voyageur
d'ailleurs sur votre album vous avez une
chanson intitulée pakistan qu'est ce qui
vous intéresse dans voyage
sellal le côté de surstimulation c'est
chez quelqu'un qui aime ça ne pas penser
quand tu es en voyage tout arrive avant
même que tu puisses vie c'est prévoir
sais tu sais pas ce qui va arriver sa
pop en pleine face c'est ce côté là que
j'aime c'est le côté impromptue
inattendue ça avant les choses encore
plus savoureux je pense pas je suis je
pense que c'est aussi la grosse fuite
j'étais en tournée pendant un an et demi
quand j'ai fini ma tournée je vais
préparer des bons de voyage parce que
j'ai aussi qu'il va falloir que
éventuellement même support d'un autre
album je pense un autre projet
le but du voyage c'est comme res était
tout ce qui est ici d'embrasser la sncf
comme j'aime bien le dire et puis après
ça on recommence à zéro t mais un
bouclier aux yeux bleus au pacte star
sapphire est passé ouais ouais tout à
fait vraiment vraiment j'ai un peuple
vraiment incroyablement hospitalier
vraiment des gens de juste la situation
de la femme je te dirait quelqu'un qui
me laissait vraiment très mal à l'aise
en fait parce qu'ils ont le presque pas
vu en fait la femme la faute au foot
mais je veux sauf
ces temps ci je trouve qu'on a dans
chaque album you numéro de téléphone que
de savoir qui répond à ce numéro
- vous allez être surpris ou philippe
mais je vous dirais que c'est moi même
qui parfois répondu au téléphone quand
j'étais à côté de ceux du téléphone donc
je sais pas fratrie côté que je veux
c'est jouer on doit trouver ça
complètement ça sonne oui
j'ai trois colloques face à ce petit
réponse à l'absence de troupeaux sur
votre album vous répondez parfois oui
absolument
quand le téléphone dans mon studio fait
que quand ça sonne au chili jégou diaz
avec du monde décrochent après quoi 24
heures sur 24 dans l'oiseau de nuit
trois zones unix l'air très tôt donc
finalement une fenêtre dans l'après midi
où je suis totalement validé l'instant
je suis à s'allumer mais ouais hurle qu
on entre dans ce souvent des appels
divers les trois ans 30 du matin sortie
des bars je pense que les gens y ont
laissé aller à ce moment l'équipe et
qu'il m'appelle plus souvent dans ces
eaux là ça arrive des fois quelqu'un moi
aussi je reviens du barbet là je réponds
puis généralement c'est des
conversations sans queue ni tête mais je
suis content parce que là je me retrouve
dans mon public
[Rires]
[Musique]
24 jeunes questions du public en termine
a fait le break
vous donnez toujours vos entrevue en
chaussettes superstitieux non pas
vraiment en fait je vais être en avance
des poches en chaussettes quand je me
mettant un beau c'était vraiment pour me
grandes dynasties chez tout le monde
savait qu'à je fais des spectacles james
est en bas champs du sol ça me permet
d'être plus grande dit je me sens plus à
l'aise puis je fais ce récemment en
entrevue
parce que c'est dans le but de me mais
ça c'est de la projection
ça marche pas tout le temps mais je me
dis que d'être anti barça va faciliter
les choses à votre cerveau tu vois pour
ça je pense que ça marche et ça
fonctionne aujourd'hui je pense qu'il
faut qu'on tienne le grac merci pas plus
compliqué que ce vin